the Mormon Church which was one of the
main backers behind prop 8 the bad side
of prop 8 they donated about 20 million
bucks to stop gay people from being
married in California and then of course
you know they're a tax-exempt
organization and that whole thing but
they are announcing now that they're
slowly pulling back from all the
anti-gay rhetoric this seems like a
great thing to me is this do you think
this is possibly something that they're
changing their beliefs or is this all
like political calculation we've lost
the war we may as well get on the crazy
game they're down like five ten percent
of their flock or whatever they call it
and then they're like we got a softener
stamp we got a soften I'm like salt like
we're like just like these degenerate
animals they're like you know and now we
can be petted the whole thing I mean
it's good right because anything where
you have the Mormon Church that has just
went above and beyond the call of duty
to rip my happiness away and now they're
just like oh my bad yeah you guys you
know we're not gonna pop all this money
in but I like how they describe they
said although the LDS is Prophet hasn't
described a holy revelation directing a
revision in the church doctrine yeah
like one day there's like oh yes I saw
the gays coming out under the rocks and
we should be nice to that like what it's
just it's just ridiculous the whole
thing is ridiculous but positive I guess
Howard I said some cynicism over there
what do you know well I worked on a book
I worked on a book last year called the
Mormon ization of America and it was by
very respected author who wrote about
Mormon Church and actually they're not
they're the one of the fastest growing
of the major religion I think there and
and you know unlike the Republican Party
the Mormon see the writing on the wall
okay and my friend Dustin Lance Black
who still considers himself a Mormon and
is in contact with the church sort of
told me you know last year that you know
they were changing their views and you
know while some people might hold
specific beliefs as a church policy they
saw no advantage to pushing that anymore
they know where society
and I do think it's a political
calculation but our own people the
Jewish people the conservative reform
sects have embraced gay marriage and gay
relationships the Orthodox not so much
so do you think it matters then I guess
you're saying it doesn't matter whether
they really believe it or they're just
coming along for the ride because they
see the gay thing as a sinking ship so
it really doesn't matter right it's our
Sex in the City
yeah I do of course you do yeah yes and
how she tried to convert you know yeah
and she kept going to the rabbi with
wine and he's like I don't want you not
the Mormon is that you knock on the door
they're tugging they're knocking on your
door they don't have to knock on you you
know
yeah and the Mormon belief is we're
gonna bring you in and even if you don't
know the teachings we're gonna offer you
that sense of community and in a world
where probably we don't live in the same
city with our parents anymore and people
feel a little lost and lonely divorce
rates are up etc that church is
important in a lot of ways and and you
know they do they've done a lot of
heinous things but there are good things
they do and they do bring a sense of
community and fellowship to people yeah
and that's a good thing in a lot of ways
and you can't and if they're less
judgmental that's a good thing do you
think that on this crazy road to
equality that we seem to be on that
there's a little danger in sort of
bending all the religions to us in a way
you know you mean if the Mormons are
coming along and you know they're
they're saying maybe this Pope will be a
little bit better but is there a weird
like acceptance that days are trying to
get that maybe is not necessary like it
should just be about the rights of
equality the crew you know given rights
by the government and not making the
religions have to dig us yeah well it's
such a loaded it's so loaded because
when you're trying to it's been it's
been so hard to cross the bridge of like
being gay and then being religious
because all the examples of just like
you can be one or the other you know and
which is really sad because there's
something wonderful about a community I
was I was raised Catholic you know about
going to the church and then my own my
parents friends though they met in their
church so there's really this
honorable things so for me it's been
very difficult to okay you feel you have
to pick so anything where there is a
bending where gay people that still have
their faith that still wanna be Catholic
wanna be Mormon where they can be
accepted in any way even if it's a
little bit I mean it's just disgusting
that it isn't a lot like that we're even
talking about this but since it was so
polarizing before that if there can be
some sort of a middle ground I think
that's a huge I think that's a huge
positive step yeah Howard as the as the
PR guy here so with all this stuff that
has moved incredibly quickly with the
gays right I mean the last two years
last two months already I mean
everything it's moving so fast is there
any advice that you would give to the
gays the gays as everyone calls them to
really just keep this momentum going I
mean are we just in a little holding
pattern now while the Supreme Court
decision I think it's bigger than all of
us I think this issue is not going away
it's we've you know the older jet the
older generation has lit a fuse in the
younger generation and they are all
about equality
you know opposition to anything having
to do with gay rights will all be gone
in 20 years because they'll all be dead
you know the people who oppose it it's
it's purely generational young people
too you know two to one you know 60 70
percent of young people don't do it they
don't care or as I like to say could you
ever watch Will & Grace or and Modern
Family and be scared of any person
really they're good they're going to do
horrible things to me what are they
going to do to you
wear a funny hat to a point where you
have to talk about this like it's just
like it's a non-issue you know like you
just don't want to have to keep beating
your head against the wall and be like
no we're normal everybody it's just you
just feel like every time you meet some
you think that's what it really comes
down to we just want to be as boring and
simple and average as you guys let us
when I used to do PR for the gay pride
parade in West Hollywood I used to take
the media you know
want to show the dykes on bikes and the
the you know the drag queens and the
Dyson speedos and I take them to the
kitchen cabinet refinishing booth I go
look we're boring bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Reuben report
I want to put you in this slim [ __ ]
shirt go to bonobos calm enter code TRR
to zero for 20% off your next purchase